over the years the MTU was managed to
make some of Marvel's most obscure
characters into household names and with
phase four coming over the horizon
who knows what little-known characters
might be brought into the limelight
these are the obscure Marvel characters
we'd love to see in phase four from the
far reaches of the burning galaxy comes
a protector of the korbinites beta ray
bill fighting against sir - and the
demons who destroy his home galaxy beta
ray bill has turned into a powerful
cyborg in order to lead the surviving
members of his race to a new planet
aboard his sentient ship the scuttle
berths
he is constantly pursued by these demons
when he reaches earth bill mistakes Thor
for a demon and they fight the Thor
shark bill is able to pick up his hammer
and users your weapon is mighty demon
but now it belongs to beta ray bill
but betters accidentally recalled to
asgard by Odin the all-father is puzzled
by what's us transpired this eventually
decided to give bill his own hammer
Stormbreaker which as it happens shares
a name with a new weapon that Thor
forges and Avengers infinity war bill
proves to be a steadfast ally of Thor
and even has a brief romance with Lady
SIF given that Thor leaves earth at the
end of Avengers endgame with the
guardians of the galaxy it would make
sense to see him run into Bill somewhere
in space moreover cert sir was last seen
wreaking havoc in Asgard serving up the
perfect opportunity to do a variation on
Bill's origin story quasar is
essentially Marvel's version of Green
Lantern he possesses cosmic powered
jewels that can create solid light
constructs in terms of personality the
gentle Wendell Vaughn is the antithesis
of swaggering arrogant superheroes like
Iron Man or Doctor Strange he thinks
before acting and generally prefers not
to fight if he can avoid it that's the
reason he has chosen as protector of the
universe by the cosmic being known as
Eon he is given unlimited power but
isn't likely to abuse it
having him meet Carol Danvers in Captain
Marvel 2 will be the best opportunity to
introduce quasar into the MCU they could
team up against one of the many weird
foes he fought over the years like the
kinetic energy absorbing Maelstrom or um
being a cosmic beast of primordial power
as a straight and narrow counterpart to
Carroll's loose cannon attitude quasar
could be a buddy a frenemy or even a
potential love interest alternatively
they could use Wendell's successor Philo
Val the daughter of Marvel that would be
a nice search on Captain Marvel story
and Carroll working with her mentors
daughter opens up all sorts of
possibilities for drama the reverend dr.
michael h EI bay is described by his
crate Sir Christopher priest as quote
the Joker to the Black Panthers Batman
more the Panther is calm collected and
compassionate a che Bey is an
unpredictable twisted lunatic genius
interested only in power a che Bey is
only too happy to kill thousands of
innocents if it helps him get his way he
also talks non-stop and constantly
insults Black Panther to his face often
referring to the super-powered kinga's
who katana which is Swahili for kitten
he literally sold his soul to the devil
or at least professed Oh in order to
gain his power and his
with him seating to Charla from his
throne things got even weirder in later
appearances what he begins to wear a
small puppet named on his arm dressed
exactly like here's a situation in
makanda is one of the biggest mysteries
of Marvel's phase for
after T'Challa and Sheree both
disappeared who assumed power what
challenges does Wakanda face after the
snap given the fact that they had just
opened themselves up to the world when
T'Challa disappeared notably a che Bay
gets himself into a condor in the comics
by exploiting conflict just to sort that
might well have arisen after the snap in
the Black Panther comics malice is a
disgraced former dora malaysia named the
kia of course in the film
Nakia is one of the heroes and the
childís love interest but it would be
easy enough to simply make malice a
different member of the Dora Malaysia
and it would be worthwhile to because
malice is a doozy of a character malice
grows up infatuated with T'Challa
dreaming that she will one day be his
queen after Mephisto puts T'Challa under
an illusion
he kisses malice and her fantasies grow
out of control no matter how much he
apologizes once he is in his right mind
as she sees it T'Challa is now hers and
she sets out to kill his girlfriend a
monocle in later kill manga helps malice
by giving her the deadly to favor hub
this poison makes her irresistible to
men and she sets out to kill every woman
into Charlie's life a completely
irrational foe is a perfect sort of foil
to the collected and consider up like
Panther and if nothing else it'd be a
pretty interesting term for the next
movie to take clear is the daughter of
Umar the unspeakable and niece of the
dread entity known as do Maru
in the comics she portrays her relatives
by helping dr. strange foil their evil
plans to conquer his dimension Clea
eventually leaves her home and becomes
dog's magical disciple and lover given
that dr. Christine Palmer was a fairly
an inspiring choice for a love interest
in the first film clear could be a
perfect addition to the cast and a
future strange movie there are all sorts
of ways Marvel could play this
considering that the time stone no
longer exists in this reality was
keeping strangest time loop spell in
place onto mama
and he invade again the Newmar tried to
take over the dark dimension Waldemar MU
was caught in the loop
in addition what's happened in the
reality where the sorcerer supreme was
absent for five years with all this in
mind the clears introduction into the
MCU seems to be just a matter of time
deep in the Everglades lives a creature
who is the guardian of the Nexus of all
realities this is the man thing amuck
encrusted monster who was once a
researcher named Ted Sallis working on
regenerative and super soldier formulas
with his colleague dr. Curt Connors Ted
was betrayed by his wife and chased down
by aim agents who were hoping to get
hold of his life's work when he crashes
into a swamp he's transformed by the
formula and the magic of the swamp into
the fearsome man thing man thing is an
empath but his brain is quite a bit
foggier than it once was when he feels a
violent anger of others he lashes out in
an effort to make it stop given the fact
that he can generate sulphuric acid this
means that people usually get hurt this
serves him well however as a guardians
of the interdimensional doorway that
lies in the swamp when malicious
entities attempt to cross over
he stands against them given that dr.
strange is said to explore the
multiverse of madness why not send him
down to Florida to do so he among things
seem like they'd have a lot to talk
about
carcass and ransack the rejects are sort
of a package deal both for deviants
genetically unstable foes of the
Eternals specifically they are mutates
deviants whose mutations are so extreme
that they are either killed or forced to
engage in brutal data toriel games in
carcasses case he's over eight feet tall
enormous ly strong bright red and has
nasty claws even by deviant standards
he's ugly but not quite as much as the
dreaded ransack the reject after a whole
lot of build-up teasing just how
horrifyingly ugly he is
the reject turns out to look a lot like
a pretty gorgeous human man he and
carcass become fast friends and the
gladiatorial pits where ransack becomes
a fearsome killing machine carcass well
good at fighting doesn't like it much in
fact he's a sensitive soul who those
philosophy and culture when thena the
eternal visits our world of Lemuria
carcass begs her to take them with her
to the Eternals home in Olympia she does
and both become valuable members of
Olympia that's the source of cinematic
journey that could make an eternal film
or sequel truly special carcass of man
sucker could be the bridge between the
eternal and deviant worlds in addition
to having their own dramatic and
effecting storyline in the comics Minaya
Shang Chi's adopted brother he earns the
nickname Midnight's erm because of his
love of the darkness evidenced by his
old black bodysuit after shang-chi
breaks away from the evils foo Manchu
midnight Sun is sent to kill his brother
and best friend a choice that brings him
great sorrow when the night eyes in
battle against shang-chi the Kree save
his life by putting his brain inside a
new clone body this gives him the
ability to enjoy the vacuum of space
turn invisible and propel himself at
great speeds all of this is in addition
to his tremendous martial arts skills
which he manages to retain midnight
summer make an ideal assassin for the
Mandarin and Shang Chi and the legend of
the ten rings
if Shang Chi's life represents a path
denied to M nigh this could make that
conflict more than just a standard hero
villains showdown
they're not just enemies but brothers
and are able to hurt each other far
worse than your typical good guy bad guy
matchup the Mandarin is reported to be
the main villain in shang-chi and the
legend of the ten ranks as powerful as
those 10 alien rings make him however
he's always use lackeys to do his
bidding that includes dr. Chen Liu
better known as the radioactive man
unlike most similarly powered heroes dr.
Liu's exposure to radiation was
intentional that in the employ of the
Chinese government he sought to make
himself immune to nuclear attack and
then dedup turning himself into a
nuclear weapon Lee was worked with a
wide variety of villains over the years
in his efforts to take down the Avengers
eventually however he has a change of
heart upon working with Crimson Dynamo
and titanium man in Vietnam there as
part of the Titanic 3 he seeks to
inflict justice some wrongdoers a change
of heart that ensures for years it'd be
great to see Liu either working for the
Mandarin in
shang-chi or acting as a free agent his
powers are formidable and his conscience
is murky a perfect recipe for an
intriguing character from us of the
slave pits of the Shiar empire come the
swashbuckling starjammers on this team
and you've got the giant screen
amphibian powerhouse chard the deadly
marksman Raza the lightning quick skunk
woman Hepzibah and the insectoid dr.
Sikorsky these ragtag misfits are led by
their human leader courser given that
Captain Marvel is out patrolling space
and Marvel is looking to bring the x-men
into the MCU fold at last now would be a
perfect time to introduce his x-men at
Jason characters the starjammers have
long been a bright ray of sunshine in
their frequent lead our mutant dramas
Corsair in facts as Cyclops and havoc
star kidnapped years prior by the Shia
their appearance could also have all the
introduction of other alien races like
the Shiar themselves or the horrific
brood starjammers a versatile or
thrilling and have a killer named
perfect for the silver screen the enigma
forces a strange essence from the
Microverse that randomly merges into
random creatures in times of need
transforming them into captain universe
it bestows a unique power upon its
recipients helps them solve the problem
at hand and then moves on as quickly as
it came whoever becomes captain universe
also gets a snappy blue and white
costume access to uni vision and control
over matter and energy first appearing
by possessing a friend of the micronauts
to help defeat the evil baron casas a
uni Power has subsequently appeared in
the prime Marvel dimension many times
it's merged with heroes such as
daredevil the Invisible Woman and the
juggernauts who used it to realign the
Earth's tectonic plates it also once
merged with the Silver Surfer to sup an
energy devouring monster there are all
sorts of intriguing possibilities for
Captain universe and the MCU
it could possess Thor or someone he
meets in his next film it could appear
as part of dr. Strange's multiverse
explorations especially since the
Microverse appeared as a quantum realm
in the MCU Captain Marvel could
encounter it while patrolling space of
course the Enigma force works best when
someone completely unexpected is given
the power uses it and then goes back to
their life making it the perfect
opportunity to power up one of the MCU
son super powered characters
you're out of luck until you've gone
done check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you